we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week as you guys know
we're building on our home studio right
now my good pal Larry King was nice
enough to lend me his studio my old
studio used to be built in this very
room but Larry lent it to us today my
guest this week is an author the
education editor at spiked and senior
lecturer of higher education an academic
practice at the University of Kent
Joanna Williams welcome to the Rubin
report hi thanks for having me
I'm very excited to talk to you because
we are going to talk about education
that might be the most important thing
out there is that fair to say I think it
is and I think what's really interesting
is how much more important it seems to
have become over just a very few yards
it seems like if everybody feels the
need to go to university nowadays and
and parents are always so worried about
how well their children are doing at
school and I think that's quite new I
don't think it used to be the case go
back 20 years I don't think it was quite
the case that everybody felt they had to
go to university and people were so
pressurized about how well their kids
were doing at school yeah so before we
get to the pressure situation and and
all the stuff that you talked about
related to it being more about grades
than learning and credits and all that
stuff how about you basically just
define education for me what do you what
do you think is actually a good
well-rounded education well I think
education should be about knowledge it's
you should know more when you leave
school than you do when you start as
great and that makes sense with you do
you know what you say it makes sense but
it's actually a very controversial thing
to say and I've been challenged upon
this so much because as soon as you say
kids should know more when they leave
school than they do when they start
school people will say to you well what
knowledge who should decide what it is
that children should know shouldn't
children just be free to explore and
tease their imaginations and to develop
as individuals and this idea that you
actually teach them something
and you actually pick what you think is
the best thing that children should know
and this goes for universe
to students as well through then you
certainly you become some kind of
elitist authoritarian who's imposing
white culture or an elitist culture on
students right I didn't realize that
education was now an elitist culture but
I think in a lot of respects it is but
you can do both of those things at the
same time right I mean you can select
what information to teach your child and
expand their knowledge well at the same
time not stifling their creativity and
ability to be themselves I mean you
don't see those things as mutually
exclusive no in fact I would actually
say that the more knowledge you give
them then the more you enable them to be
free to use their imaginations and to
become creative thinking critical
individuals because they've got some
basis to form that create to form that
creativity to spark that criticality but
the problem nowadays I think is that so
many people so many educators bizarrely
enough think that you can miss out that
first stage that you can miss out
teaching people any actual knowledge and
just jump straight into the let's be
critical let's be imaginative let's be
creative bit without doing the
groundwork first and I think the more
you actually teach people stuff proper
stuff then the more you enable them to
be free thinking creative critical yeah
it was so I know that this portion isn't
totally your expertise but as I was
doing my research for this I kept
thinking I have a two-year-old niece who
is just going into whatever that that's
not elementary skincare candlenut even
kindergarten it's you know preschool
whatever it's just to sort of socialize
and take naps and stuff like that it
sounds pretty great actually
um how much do you know or or pay
attention to just sort of the process of
younger learning before I know your
focus is really on universities and
stuff like that
but how much of just you know doesn't
have to be two-year low but from two to
say eighteen how much of that is
important to you and important to what
leads to the stuff that you really care
about at the University I think it's all
important I think it's all really
important but you know the bizarre thing
as well is that so many people who are
involved in education like say they talk
the rhetoric of creativity imagination
child centered is the language of the
day you know everybody's got to be very
very child centered and yet when it
comes to
two-year-olds like you're talking about
we can't leave them alone so you know
between two and ten or whatever it is
it's like people can't neat micromanage
every step of their day everything they
do I mean if I was running a nursery for
two-year-olds I think I'd have nice toys
big open area you know this is for
kindergarten kids and leave them to get
on with it
leave them to play to form friendships
relationships fall out fight hey Chris
which is all apart that's a type of
education it's not necessarily the
question of knowledge per se at five
years old socializing but socializing is
education right it is but but I think
the best socializing is done obviously
you know you you have a relationship
with the parents the relationship with
the teachers but ultimately kids need to
be left alone as well
so my daughter's ten in her school this
week it's anti-bullying week and I can
guarantee you one thing the poor teacher
next week is going to have so many more
kids coming to see him to say that
they're being bullied because
essentially what these kids are being
taught is that the normal everyday
interactions that you have when you're
10 where you're falling out with people
making up with people that that is now
bullying yeah and instead of just
leaving the kids to get on with it sort
it out for themselves they're being told
oh no this is bullying right that was
traumatic
yeah you have to sort of tell on that no
to top yourself go and tell the teacher
yeah so now I know a certain amount of
people are gonna hear that because I've
seen this when I've said something like
that not I'm not Pro bullying but I do
understand that when I was a kid there
were some kids that I made fun of
sometimes there were some kids that made
fun of me sometimes there I was playing
stickball on sin about fourth grade and
two guys that were much bigger than me
from I think two grades over literally
picked me up and put me upside down in a
garbage can I'm not making that up so I
was bullied and I did some bullying but
that's all which makes you a person it
does but I think what's changed is that
the definition of bullying has gone from
being something where we were quite
clear about it if somebody hits you and
that was bullying and you know if you
were being hit badly enough you could go
and tell the teacher and you would
expect an adult to intervene and tell
whoever was hitting you to stop suddenly
now bullying has gone from being hitting
to name
falling now it's not even name-calling
it's leaving someone out ah so even if
someone doesn't do anything bad to you
they just don't do anything to you yeah
that it's now seen as being bullying as
well that reminds me of like in like
third or fourth grade when you know if
it was somebody's birthday you'd have to
bring cupcakes for everybody you see but
in the UK at the time but now it's gasps
yeah you have oh we had that in the
States for a long time I remember very
specifically there was one kid who I
really really hated and I was like I
don't want to give him a cupcake on my
birthday but you have to bring cupcakes
for everybody because they're left out
what do you think that does to two
children for their formative years this
sort of because all you're doing is
giving them a fake reality I don't want
to exclude kids and I get kids can be
tough and rough and mean and all that
stuff but what do you think it does for
their formative ability to feel some
pain which is part of life yeah I mean
we use this term snowflake generation
and I think I don't particularly like
that term but you can see how these kids
are being then formed in school that
nothing bad should ever ever happen to
you and if something bad does happen to
you it's the end of the world and there
is no way you can be expected to sort it
out for yourself you need to go and get
somebody else to come in to sort this
out for you and you know the reason why
I don't particularly like the terms
snowflake generation is because it lets
older people off the hook and these kids
don't go to school when they're five
begging for anti-bullying weeks you know
it's being given to them by some older
solutely and this is the teachers yeah
and the head teachers who are saying we
are now going to have anti-bullying week
which I promise you won't be just a week
ago on yeah but this is what teachers
are doing to them so the teachers are
telling them essentially you are so
fragile
you cannot cope if somebody gives you a
slightly odd look yeah and you cannot
sort that out for yourself and go and
say to the person why are you looking at
me in that way you need to get some help
so they're being conditioned to be
scared of everything and everyone and
never to be able to sort anything out
for them
selves so these are then the kids who
are then arriving on the college campus
at University for five years on from
this completely unable to cope forming
relationships with each other yeah so
before they get there what do you think
the learning process should be like so
now we've talked about the young kids
the preschoolers we've sort of got
through elementary school what sort of a
healthy high school education to you
where you're not necessarily going into
the the deep philosophical stuff but
maybe are but you know you're not
college level but you're not a kid
anymore those interesting years well I
think for me one of the big problems at
the moment with education is that the
role of the teacher has become so
confused with the role of for parents
and I think the job of the parent is to
kind of love the kids obviously but to
do things like teaching them about
healthy eating to bring them up in their
values to teach them about sex and
relationships for example that should be
the job of the parent and it should be
the job of the school to teach kids
knowledge to teach them about works of
literature about maths geography history
proper subjects and the problem is these
roles have become completely blurred so
the school is stepping in and teaching
sex and relationships education teaching
about consent teaching about bullying
about friendships and the parents are
being expected to teach the maths and
teach the really bizarre um and I think
what a good school education should be
like is both doing more in terms of more
teaching teaching more proper subject
knowledge to kids but then hands off as
well don't teach them about sex and
relationships and this is a really
controversial thing to say in the UK but
but I don't think it should be the job
of teachers to be telling kids about sex
and relationships it shouldn't be the
job of the teachers to be running
anti-bullying wings it shouldn't be the
job of the school to tell kids what
values to hold so the teachers are kind
of overstepping the mark I think but
also not doing enough in terms of proper
teaching of subject knowledge right so
do you think there's no role for say
seventh grade health class where they're
not I started teaching about sex per se
but they are teaching about STDs or
they're teaching about drug use or
something like that you would say that's
more of an academic thing so you are
okay with that or you think that even
that really I wouldn't have any of that
at all I mean I think obviously there's
a case for teaching kids the biology
yeah that should be done in a science
lesson but as soon as you move beyond
the biology you're putting a values
framework into this so even if you take
healthy eating for example I do not
think it should be the role of the
school to teach kids want to eat so
remember my own son when he was about
seven and we'd had a very very busy week
it was very stressful and got to Friday
and I all will get a pizza for dinner
there's gluten in there what's wrong
with you oh no we didn't have to you
know this is a bit more yeah well you
had it but you weren't talking about we
were talking about it yeah um but he'd
been asked by the school to keep a food
diary this is like a seven year old boy
here you know spent so much time running
around he was so skinny
yeah and had been asked to write down
everything that he'd had to eat and to
kind of color code it green for good red
for bad it actually sounds scary to me I
just think it's completely over stuff
from the mark and I'm like what come on
I'm your mother and I want you to eat a
pink that you really do listen I don't
care how many calories it's got it had a
bizarro land that is where the mother
has to trick the kid into that's really
no but I mean I think the healthy eating
is one thing but I think when it comes
into sex and relationships it becomes
even more horrible because it is a
complete moral agenda that children are
being taught and this then feeds into
universities where you have certainly in
the UK demands for consent classes now I
mean bizarrely compulsory consent
classes well these classes are mandatory
they must go to learn how to say no
right um so what do you do about the the
kid so not who has a stable family and
parents and parents we're going to teach
them the right things but for a kid that
really is not going to get that
knowledge from them they're not going to
learn how to eat properly or how to not
do drugs or know things about their body
all
that's up which is fully legit and I
understand you're drawing a line between
sort of personal life and and the
schooling system but how can we then
help those kids that obviously do you're
confusing time how do you had it is
there some role for the public in that I
mean firstly I wouldn't overstate it I
mean people always throw it you know
what about these really extreme examples
these kids who are kind of growing up in
a garbage can or something like that
don't have any human interaction I think
it could be really really careful I mean
I think the vast majority of parents
love their children and want the best
for their children and do the best that
they can and it might not be textbook
and it might not be more the experts say
you should do but most there is no
recipe at the end of the day for how to
raise the perfect kid and I think we
fool ourselves if we think there is some
recipe for raising the perfect kid and I
think you know talking to them loving
them that is enough actually and I think
the vast majority of parents do that but
you know there always will be one or two
who perhaps don't have the advantages
and don't get that love from their
parents and that's really sad but you
know what I think teachers are human and
tend to love their jobs and also tend to
be fond of the kids that they teach and
I think teachers over decades have
always had an ugly out I certainly my
own teaching experience you would have
half an eye out for the kid who was
sitting there looking very quiet
withdrawn you know if you thought
someone had come to school without
breakfast that day and you would help
the man and you would do that on a very
individual level but the problem is when
you start seeing your role as a teacher
to do this to everyone in the class that
you've got to teach 30 kids about
healthy eating that takes up so much of
your time and energy that poor kid who's
sitting there looking very withdrawn who
has come to school without breakfast you
actually don't even have the time to
notice them and to give them the
individual attention yeah she's so busy
looking after all the worried well kids
yeah that's such an interesting example
of sort of the collective versus the
individual because by choosing the
collective in effect you have to sort of
neglect the people that need it the most
which is so if that's really it's
well-intentioned I suppose it want to
teach these kids about how to eat right
and then who do you end up hurting the
most is the kid that you could have
focused on I think that's true I think
that's true but I also think you know
there's just such a tendency nowadays to
assume the worst of people and to assume
that parents are not up to the job of
raising their own kids and that makes me
feel very sad because I think it's
untrue I think like so then people might
not do it all according to some mythical
rule book but I think most parents are
up to the job of raising their kids and
we're always so quick to focus on the
one or two extremes and and luckily they
are extremes I think most parents
genuinely want the best for their kids
and genuinely love their kids and they
may not be raising their kids in the
best circumstances or circumstances that
they've chosen but they do want the best
for their children and I think we're
just always so quick to look on the bad
side yeah
so speaking of wanting the best for
their children so you mentioned your
daughter now 10 years old anti-bullying
week in light of what you do for a
living and the things that you care
about I mean what do you say to her
either before this during inter after do
you know what these are real dilemmas at
that I face as a parent because I mean
before anti-bullying week I promise you
I'm not making this up but the week
before anti-bullying week was so you
don't you I don't think you'll have this
charity here in the US but we have this
charity NSPCC
which is the National Society prevent
for prevention of cruelty to children
and the week before anti-bullying week
this charity came into the school to do
a week-long series of workshops about
sexual abuse with ten year olds and they
have this initiative called pants and
it's about telling children that nobody
should be allowed to touch you inside
your underwear again you could say isn't
this perhaps useful for the one or two
children who are being sexually abused
but you take her school 400 children in
it you know 395 of them do not need to
have lessons in sexual abuse and it
creates worry and concern and fear in
those children where they've got nothing
to fear about and it makes them
suspicious of that
parents you know make some suspicious of
adults who are wanting to help them and
it creates this kind of fear in in the
heads of young kids so I get these
letters home you know this week is
sexual abuse prevention week this week
is anti-bullying week healthy eating
week yeah I live just a regular one
Ivanova nervous back row late week they
don't have bad or we're not going to
bother you this week no I mean over the
years there's been some really bizarre
things so this was going back years now
but this school was into a fair trade
and that Trump this is when she was like
six so how can they get six year olds to
think about fair trade so they made
posters of bananas and pictures and
cutting out and all this kind of thing
against six-year-olds really understand
that international economics that this
is the thing cuz it's they don't
obviously they understand it and there's
no pretense of even teaching them about
International Economics and world trade
it's just preaching and it's just values
so when they draw the poster they're not
expected to think critically about these
things they're expected just buy into
the values and demonstrate have met
these values so they all want pictures
of kind of bananas and then farmers
saying I like Fairtrade and this kind of
thing with no degree of criticality
there at all right and then if you dare
criticize it then you haven't
demonstrated that you've met the value
so you failed when did this happen
when when did this stuff really happen
cuz as I said before when I was a kid I
bullied and I was bullied I remember you
know that we were allowed to get into
fights and all of that stuff and you try
to settle it you know with between the
parents and not make everything national
headline when did this happen and was it
the exact same timing for the United
States as it was for Britain I think I
think probably quite similar in terms of
timing I mean I think there's lots of
different things going on here I think
you can see for example one very very
interesting study shows the geographical
distance that children were allowed to
go from their home on their own
away from home and you can see how since
the 1970s you're on yeah that distance
that children are allowed to go has
become smaller and smaller
so essentially nowadays it's pretty much
their back garden yeah I mean you're
talking about literally like their
ability to get on the bike and ride
around the neighborhood slowly things go
smoothly yeah yeah which is sad very
very sad and you can look at kind of
high-profile cases I think in both the
States and in the UK of children who
maybe have been abducted and how this
then spreads the fear through parents
and this idea that we're all kind of
monitoring each other all the time so I
let my daughter walk to school on her
own my or with with another boy from her
class my fear and this is very very
revealing my fear was not one second
about anything that would happen to my
daughter you know she's very sensible
girl she absolutely fine my fear was
what will other parents think of me and
it's that idea that we're all kind of
checking and monitoring each other all
the time yeah that's really unhealthy
that's the big what do what do some of
the parents think of you as long as as
long as we're going that route I mean
your public about this this is what you
yeah she walks to school every day and
everybody drives past and sees her
walking to school every day yeah um you
know people are people saying funny
things to me like oh you're so lucky you
can do that because you're gasa sensible
no she's just a regular kid she's just
the same as your child there yeah why
she sensible is because I've allowed her
right it's not a coincidence that you
got this sensible yeah yeah it's because
I've let her take these risks that she
now is this sensible child but people
come up and they will say oh I saw her
walking to school on her own today and
it's almost as if they just want me to
know that they know that she's walking
on her own yeah um so it's really it's
like big brother study at a very micro
level because they start it's almost a
way of it's not just that they're
surveying the kids in a way they're
surveying the parents and they're and
now you're all kind of watching each
other so it really it's it sounds
extremely perverted or something like
because I do
this comes from the school so kids will
bring home for example homework projects
that they there is no possibility of the
children being able to complete these
projects on their own you know and the
homework projects are actually designed
to involve the parents and it's as if
the school is then checking up on what
what are the parents doing are the
parents being good parents have the
parents heard the child read and so you
have home school liaison officers who
are employed specifically to work with
the parents rather than working with the
children bringing the parents into
school and we have parenting classes in
the UK now and all parents are Inc are
encouraged to go to these parenting
classes and it's almost as if if you
turn around it so I actually do you know
what I think I'm doing a good enough job
I don't think I need any of this extra
help or advice that in and of itself and
marks you out to somebody who's not good
enough right so by doing a good job thus
not wanting to spend extra time in a
class that you no need for you then are
then thought of as the outsider and
something's wrong with those guys I
don't want to be the parenting class
they both bring because they're not good
parents this is crazy so so how do you
peel back some of this stuff I think
you've got to I think and you just have
to stand up and take that risk and you
just have to them no she's 10 my
daughter you know she's walking to
school and that's it end of story and it
the time I think it becomes very very
difficult for me personally the time it
becomes very difficult is with things
like these anti-bullying weeks and say
sex education classes because I
obviously have strong opinions about
these things but I'm also aware that I
don't want to single my daughter out and
I don't want her to have to carry the
can for my political views and most of
the time I just let these things go and
then I'll ask her about it afterwards
and see if there's anything that she
wants to talk to me about but I won't
single her out there's one or two things
where I do so for example I was talking
about the healthy eating thing and they
do this thing in the UK one day
a-and measure all children when they're
in the first year at school and when
they're in their final year at school so
they can send a letter home to the
parents to say you know your child is
obese your child is overweight and you
need to do something about this and
here's some exercise classes and says
you couldn't have figured that out on
your own no way
you couldn't have bought a scale and
maybe fed your kid differently that
would be impossible absolutely I mean
that's the assumption that you need
somebody to give you an official letter
to say your child is overweight
you know it's horrendous so I would drew
her from that you know she's not going
to do do that but most of the time you
have to let it go and then you just have
to hope that your children pick up
enough of your own values that
eventually they begin to think quite
critically of these things themselves